[Music]
hispanic heritage month honors the
history and culture of the latin
american communities and
la bonita supermarket is helping you
find some delicious ways to celebrate
when it comes to celebrating hispanic
heritage month la bonita supermarkets
has you covered celeste it is great to
see you oh i'm so excited to see you jc
finally you get to meet again with us
first off so how do people celebrate
hispanic heritage month well obviously
as you can see hispanics
love food and drinking so we always
celebrate it with food because
food brings everyone together and that's
including all of the
you know hispanic heritage countries
brings them all together to one store
now let's talk about some of the
products that we have you want to make
something from scratch la bonita markets
as a place to be so where are some of
the stuff we have here
so right over here we have a few
different products so right here we have
um
different condiments and different
juices that you can use for cooking
purposes
we all have them here so depending on
what type of food you cook in your
country
you'll be able to find it here right
over here we also have
products to make the famous pupusas and
we
have also products to make you know
the different dishes that we use here so
this year is the yerba mate which makes
great tea
yes it makes great tea it makes great
mate
and this is actually a very very healthy
way you can also make it as a tea
in the coffee pot which i just learned
to do that and also we have plenty of
beer and
drinks to go along with a celebration of
hispanic heritage month of course we
have for mexican beers we have this uh
peruvian beer
we have okay severe and i do believe
that we also have an
argentinian beer beautiful i see the man
of the hour with all the power mr wow
get in here mr wow is here
get over here it's ready because you
have plenty of pre-made dishes what are
some of the pre-made dishes we have here
so this is actually a very famous in
cuba
with arrozcon
here those are bananas those are
actually flat
this is actually a vegetarian you can
cut it and put cheese in there and it's
covered with breading on the side it
looks so good we have it a lavonita too
you can come and get it here the last
two items are at the end
so we have the famous venezuelan pupusas
and
shredded meat and you can put that on
tacos if you want to or not
on a tortilla it's delicious now you see
everything here at la bonita you can get
the ingredients make everything from
scratch or homemade
food for you guys fully prepared to
celebrate hispanic heritage month
as we get ready to wrap up mr wow what's
the one item i should try
i mean all right another black beans and
rice oh black
cuban favorite i am half cuban let me
give it a taste oh there you go
great for breakfast too so good
celebrate hispanic heritage month here
at la monito supermarkets send it back
to you guys
good stuff there are several la bonita
supermarkets in the vegas valley
you can click on bonitamarkets.com to
find the location
nearest you more las vegas now